so let's talk about you know getting
Steve attached to the project I mean was
it something I mean first off it was he
an easy person to contact and was he the
fall so the first sort of name that you
tried to contact I often am told by
other directors how easy something is
but usually directors that haven't done
it okay so nothing is easy that I've
done with getting with getting people to
return my calls or to answer the phone
you know it's it's after rewriting and
writing and writing and writing and
rewriting and doing this and this the
work work work work work work work
getting a hold of these people you just
have you just have to do it you can't be
afraid I can't be afraid so many people
are afraid you know what's there to be
afraid of you know what's the worst
thing they're gonna say no you know why
would they say no everybody wants to
make money you know well I'll sit over
here with other 30,000 scripts we're
getting you know they might be getting a
lot of scripts but they're not gonna you
have to believe in yourself and if it
doesn't work go on to the next guy you
know so so how many people did you try
to contact or was the first one he was
the first one and yes so so once you
make the contact his manager then
contact him through through the manager
and then how difficult was it to get the
manager the script to pass on the slope
I had I had a little bit of a this again
goes back to opportunity everything is
an opportunity this goes back to having
a film with a distributor that had in
his catalog films with name actors so I
immediately told the manager as he tried
to hang up on before he could hang up on
me wait a second we have distribution
with a production company that your
actor just worked with there was my end
you see so they're all little bits of
opportunity little business everything
connecting and before that first film
got the distribution it was a play that
one of the actors that I hired brought
her uncle or cousin in who was a
distributor everything is just connected
everything is connected so it's you have
to and these people everybody's business
I think especially higher up they're all
looking for that good fellow type of
thing where they want to hear not not
the gangster thing but statement of like
he's all right he's a good guy he's all
right meaning you've worked with
somebody so they know you're not a
negative person because they have to be
protective because there's so many
people you know i'm not saying half but
there's a lot that will just throw the
mom on her train to make in this
business you know and you have to be the
person that would jump in front of the
train to save the mother so you're able
to keep the manager on the phone and
you're and you're able you can you take
a sort of beyond that initial contact
about getting like Steve you know it's
obviously get him the script from there
and then then what happened I was blown
away you know I sent him that cinema
script in the end and I got a call back
you know and and they were just talking
about the script and it was a new it was
a good play it was based at with an
award-winning play we want a grant at a
performance art center and was writing
the big time of the big health care
debate you know going on and in the
United States and it was a lot about
that so then he called me right back and
then so and then he wants to meet with
you or no no no no the meeting the
business had to be taken care of once
business once the business is taken care
of the ones the actor decides that he
wants to do a script
then business is taken care of okay and
then you have a meeting with the actor
and that's that's what happens you know
and I respect that mmm and what was that
I mean were there certain promises and
guarantees that you had to have in place
in order for Steve Bloomberg to commit
to the project he had to make sure the
project had distribution had to make
sure the project you know he was going
to get paid what he wanted to get paid
you gotta make sure that you know all
the legalities were taken care of you
know and uh he'd really liked the script
and you know and uh was worked with me
and we're able to get him what he needed
and I was able to get what I needed and
you said once his name was attached to
the project then sort of the money came
in can you keep him can you elaborate
you're not in any way again it's the
same thing as I always speak of this um
people other people you know working
with you it's um believing in you and
wanting things to work out for you you
know I didn't go to a bank later on my
career I've been able to borrow for the
money for the pink for projects but uh
early on I've got help from private
investors you know people that knew what
I was doing we're following my career
and I think if you're out there doing
something it's it's easier to get
somebody to believe in you you know
you're just setting at home with the
script in your drawer you know you gotta
do more than that and would you have
would you have distribution in place if
it wasn't for Steve Greenberg what I
mean was having a name was it that
important in regards to your
relationship with the distributor I
think I'm not gonna be honest with you I
believe one hundred percent that the
distributor was the first thing they
noticed was the name but the first thing
that people say when they see the film
first day talk about the name then I
talk about the film and they talk about
the director they talk about the other
actors you know steve has just gets
people's attention because he's you know
he's a legend um but we made a good film
and it was Yuki you know it wouldn't
have been getting as much attention as
it has if it was just you know piece of
crap with a name in it it's a great film
and he he's what gets people's attention
are you know then they go didn't they
start talking about the film which is
exactly what I want him to happen he is
all you know so that's that's pretty
much how I feel about that
you